marc est vite il fait partir par une
nuit si noir pour ne revenir annoncé ce
retour sosie vallée est chargé par
amphitryon de prévenir son épouse de son
succès mais il est remplacé par mercure
qui prend ses traits amphitryon est une
comédie en trois actes de molière je
trouve que c'est la pièce la plus folle
de manière la plus pour moi la plus
mystérieuse de la plus peut-être intime
aussi celles dans la calle d'aminé chose
certaine les plus profondes les plus
secrètes de lui c'est louis nous confie
son rapport au ciel à l'au-delà à tout
ce qui n'est pas humain on connaît le
mot liens humains humaniste mais là on
découvre un molière habité par une fois
c'est moi qui suis senti une pièce sur
la symétrie sur la gémellité une mise en
scène épurée où la ressemblance est à
voir dans l'ain du jeu des comédiens
elle suppose évidemment des acteurs
extraordinaires que j'ai la chance
d'avoir autour de moi des interprètes
d'une grande puissance intérieure parce
que la ressemblance n'est pas forcément
uniquement physique elle est aussi dans
les sentiments
c'est une pièce sur la vérité pour moi
in où est la vérité sur un plateau de
théâtre c'est l'acteur et le plateau nu
cette espèce de façon très très pur et
très simple très humble de porter le
texte comme simplement un ambassadeur de
ce texte qui est quand même un
chef-d'oeuvre absolu
les dix comédiens font vivre cette
oeuvre du dramaturge français écrites en
1668 une oeuvre peu connue du grand
public dans un écrin de choix la grande
écurie du roi